the New England Patriots went into the
Superbowl 53 saying we're still here and
they came out as NFL champions well this
morning take a look at the Boston Globe
it says the dynasty rolls on after the
Pats beat the LA Rams 13 to 3 last night
nowadays the six Super Bowl title for
quarterback Tom breaky Brady
he's breaky Brady he breaks the records
because it is an all-time record
Patriots fans in downtown Boston were
only slightly less happy than Norah
O'Donnell they celebrated after the game
that was unexpectedly dominated by
defense CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Dana Jacobson is outside
mercedes-benz Stadium in Atlanta Dana
good morning good morning John Super
Bowl 53 was the lowest scoring Super
Bowl in history I guess it proves the
point that defense does win
championships
it was a record-tying sixth title for
New England 41 year old quarterback Tom
Brady and his 66 year old head coach
Bill Belichick now the oldest at their
respective positions to hoist that
Lombardi Trophy the dynasty continues it
wasn't pretty but for Tom Brady and the
New England Patriots it was enough with
over a hundred million expected viewers
here in the United States they saw more
of this
second and three unless of this escape
for the first time in Super Bowl history
there wasn't a single touchdown for
three quarters of football and with
offensive momentum hard to come by
the halftime show provided the fireworks
we expected from the game maroon 5 led
by frontman Adam Levine along with
Travis Scott and big boy the game's only
touchdown broke a fourth-quarter
stalemate giving the Patriots a 10 to 3
lead 1 they would never relinquish look
at this it's not motivate you is what
it's all about
every year it's got to feel different
for you what is this win like this to me
this one was I actually thought the
first one there'll be nothing like it
and each one has been different and
special how sweet is this one all the
ones you've had it's sweet it's sweet
Jim everybody counted us out from the
beginning of the seasons midseason
but we're still here they are still here
you know I got a chance to talk to Tom
Brady's dad after the game I asked him
if he was nervous at all during the game
and he said no because we've been here
before and they have think about this
this was the largest margin of victory
for a Patriots team winning by 10 they
hadn't won by more than seven points
before they'll be holding their victory
parade on Tuesday yes the long drought
is over in Boston this victory parade
just about three months after they had
won for the Red Sox who beat that other
LA team the Dodgers Nora Dana thank you